hey Android developers I'm Joe Fernandez
of the Android developer relations team
today I'll explain how to record a video
of your Android app using the new screen
record feature of Android KitKat to use
this feature you'll need a device
running Android KitKat like the Nexus 5
and a microUSB cable no video camera
required
so why record a video of your Android
app good question a video is an
effective way to demonstrate your app
and it gives users a quick way to see
how your app works what it can do before
they download it so it's a great
promotional tool creating a video that
explains how to use advanced features or
correct common mistakes is also a great
use of that videos is there a question
about your application you get asked
over and over record a video to show
your users how it's done so what do you
need to use the screen record feature
well you need a device using running
Android KitKat such as the Nexus 5 you
also need a computer with the Android
debug bridge installed if you have an
Android software development kit
installed on your machine then you
already have ADB finally you'll need a
micro USB cable to connect the computer
to your device as I mentioned you don't
need a video camera to use screen record
however this feature does not record
audio so if you want to narrate your
video you need to use something to
record your voice as your demo I
recommend using a second Android device
with an app that has high-definition
voice recording here are the steps to
record a video first connect your USB
cable from your computer to your device
then make sure it's working by running a
test command such as adb devices type
the screen record command to start
recording and then perform your demo on
the device if you're doing narration of
your demo don't forget to turn on your
voice recorder when you're done with
your demo press the control C to enter
the recording finally download the
recorded video to your computer using
the pull command
here's a video I recorded using the
screen record feature it shows a quick
walkthrough of the android kitkat user
interface I recorded this video using
only commands I just showed you notice
that there are no hands or fingers in
this video this is a direct recording of
the screen activity including the
animations and user actions the moving
circle is a touch indicator I'll explain
how to turn on that indicator later in
this video
here are some pro tips for producing a
great app video write a rough script of
the or outline of what you want to demo
the script doesn't have to be elaborate
just listing a few key steps will help
you create a complete video more quickly
practice the demo a couple of times
before recording it practicing will
improve the quality of your presentation
and help you discover parts of your demo
where you can improve your flow pay
attention to the speed of your on-screen
actions if your explanation is lagging
behind your on-screen gestures slow down
and try pausing between actions use the
developer settings to show touches this
option displays that moving circle you
saw in my demo video during this feature
on in the Settings app it's in the
developer options page under the input
heading record while you demonstrate
your app adding this makes adding
narration to your video a lot easier
also remember to start recording video
before you start audio recording that
makes it easier to fit your audio to
your video during editing finally use a
separate microphone before recording
your voice built-in microphones work but
you'll typically get better audio
quality with a separate microphone
that's held close to your mouth YouTube
is a great way to distribute your video
you can use YouTube's Video Editor to do
some basic editing including adding a
music track which can make your
promotional videos a lot more engaging
if you're adding narration to your video
you'll need to use a video editor
application to add your voice audio
track to your video before you upload it
to YouTube on windows check out Movie
Maker for this purpose on Apple iMovie
and on Linux try kdenlive for more
details of the screen record feature of
KitKat check out this link I have a
great time making those app videos
I'm Joe Fernandez and thanks for
watching